welcome back to drew's news now there's
a very special story that caught my eye
and it's gone viral across the country
and for good reason
okay so listen to this 23 students were
arrested for fighting last month at
southwood high school in shreveport
louisiana and a group of dads knew that
they needed to step in and make a change
so they created dads on duty usa
and guess what
they're here
that's right
in a daytime exclusive interview as part
of our good dad program
please welcome michael lafitte
david halsey michael morgan and zachary
johnson
first of all thank you guys so much for
making your way here and what i'm so
excited about is i can ask you
why you started this and what the
intention michael like how did this
happen how did you come up with the idea
so what happened is uh
after about two days of cis fights and
other things going on at the campus um
just a group of parents decided to meet
downtown shreveport and you know we said
that this isn't the narrative this isn't
the school that we'd like to send our
kids to so opposed to other people
stepping in uh this group of fathers
here we just decided to say you know
what let us be the first ones to take
back our campus uh who other than to
step in the gap and to parent our kids
than the actual parents uh so we had
that meeting on that sunday we were at
the campus the next day at 7 30 in the
morning boots on the ground doing what
we have to do to show love and respect
for our kids
michael morgan what has the response
from students been like um we first when
we first got there we um kind of
received a little rebellion but it was
because the fact that they hadn't seen
love
um
now the kids are the students are more
so responding to us
um we learned that
some of the children come to school with
issues at the home
so when we talk to them we try to
freshly open them up and we try to let
them know that we love them
and now we're starting to get students i
went to a game the other night and i had
probably 50 students walk up to me
just saying just just saying how much
that they appreciate it
you know that we were there
that's phenomenal
that must be very encouraging go ahead
well i love that the students are coming
up to you and saying they're glad you're
there but what about your own kids are
they like this is cool or they're like
damn
my my children uh usually get out of the
truck and run from me
[Laughter]
yeah that's like every movie is like mom
dad
okay david you started this program with
just a few dads um and it seems like
more and more people are joining the
cause yes it's more and more joining
calls uh
we are we are planning to expand and uh
move to other parishes in other
districts and uh
we have i think it's like i think about
40 dads at this time 40 yes oh my gosh
that's a movement you guys started
what i
love
is that
i heard you guys want to expand so i
think this is a good blueprint also
for people to know that they can
volunteer they can help with this
i mean i just love what you guys are
doing so much i'm so in fact
um
and you have our support um and we're
gonna send you home with four thousand
dollars a thousand dollars to each of
you and we want to put it towards your
initiative and there is a gofundme that
you're doing so we're going to put that
up on our website at the
drewberrymoreshow.com so anyone who
would like to contribute this is a spark
let it become a brush fire of good
thank you for protecting our children
thank you michael david
[Applause]
[Music]